like i missed my flight with my mate he
went back and i'm like you know i missed
it for a reason
i'm gonna go and and i explored the
region and then the fact that i found
the vietnamese people
what's mad i remember at the time when i
when i met the sheikh
of the school he was like we need 25
grand for the water project i'm thinking
in my head
who does he think i am does he think i'm
some rich boy like i don't
i don't have a spare 25k to give you
like in my head i'm like yeah inshallah
and he said this two years ago when i
posted that video it went viral
and i was like bro i have to do
something and then my dad was like
pressing me to do it i could go for me
and then
we raised that in like less than a week
and i'm like super
a lot the fact that he mentioned to me
and i even at the time
i was just thinking i wish bro that's
another
crazy concept it's like at least when
you die you know there's
heaven and hell some people are they
think halas that's it it's over
die and it's finished you know lights
out you're going to wish that
on the day of judgment
when the animals before allah they come
because allah is all just he will take
the right
of one animal from the other and when
that's done they will turn to dust and
this believer look at them be like i
wish
if only you know
[Music]
[Music]
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively more than you're influencing
them positively
i think you need new friends
and welcome back to the three muslims
podcast and we are joined today
with our brother
the other day about like joining the
podcast and i'm like i
think i've done only one podcast and was
one of one of my friends
so i'm like always reluctant to do
podcasts you know because especially
from me i just sometimes just chat
chat chat and uh i looked through the
podcast and there was
there was one it was episode 52
and it was like the jin series bro oh my
god that was a mad podcast i actually
can't wait for that
uh part two because i was looking i
finished it it was like an hour
and then i was like where's the part two
oh my god i still haven't posted so
hopefully by the time you post this
the part two will be posted inshallah
bro part two was already posted part two
dropped
last night oh it is oh okay okay okay
okay okay
and we finished we filmed part three
today on psychedelics dmt
all that bro because um like
i listen to joe rogan i listen to all
these lads and um
you know sometimes i'm like bro how are
they having all the same
experiences and talking like this
thing's mad but i've never
like i have you know knowledge on gin
and
and things like that and i know but
sometimes you don't correlate these
things
do you get me so then so then when i was
like
that makes so much sense how did i not
think of that you know
that you know when they when they take
this drug it removes that hijab
and you know obviously because jin they
possess you for a few reasons
you're in a certain state of massa
then they can enter or you know when
you're intimate with your spouse that's
why you make
the dua that's why you say bismillah or
if you're walking around naked around
your house
and they can fall in love with you when
they can enter you you know um there's a
few
it's it's rare you get me or you can
take drugs
and that is also a state of massey and
hammer
and it's easier for them to enter and
i'm like bro
because i used to listen to it and i'm
like how are they all seeing the same
thing
you know it can't be made up then yeah
what your mind said i forgot his name is
he was like they just believe anything
that jin's telling them
like it's the word of god to them
they're like whoa like these voices in
my head they came to me and they were
saying xyz
well you know these gym bro they're
gonna lie to you might destroy you off
the
path and usually if they're gonna
possess even they're not gonna be muslim
jin
so they're not gonna be they're gonna be
the the uh the evil coin but that was so
interesting man like i'm gonna
definitely listen to part two right
after this
love a good jin story to be honest
you don't need to tell us on the air if
you're not comfortable but do you have
any experience with gin have you had any
encounters do i have any experiences
bro you know what one of my first
experiences when we were doing km
laid and there was a man i felt so bad
for him it was like one of my first
times first of all i seen someone who
wasn't fasting in ramadan in the last 10
days and he was like drinking water and
just like shaking and i'm like
i was like i don't know eight years old
and i was thinking man
why is this going off fast and i didn't
think he was the other genuine or
whatever and then turns out my quran
was actually the one giving him you know
i think that was like the first and only
time where i've seen it in person where
i've seen someone
being possessed you know because
sometimes you always hear about these
stories
but you never actually you know see
somebody
uh going through it or experiencing it
so
that was like the first time i ever saw
and to be honest like sometimes
you know when you realize jin is real
puts a lot of things into perspective
it's like that's the world of the unseen
that's part of it what else has been
seen
you know that that literally growing up
in canada seeing you know ghosts
uh demons spirits witches movies and all
that i was like bro this is fake this is
like
you know it's just for entertainment and
then reading in the quran talking about
jin
it just literally consolidates how you
know it has to be the truth they exist
they're all around us
so how did you take that
they see you from where you cannot see
them you know it's not something that
you talk about every day or whatever
it's not something they experience every
single day but
listen in the end of the day you do your
earthquake i mean you look after
yourself
there's also people in my life that i
know two people that i know that
got possessed for real for real and i
remember the first time
the rocky actually showed me a video of
like them losing
in like he's filming and he was like
speaking to them and this was like
a person that was close uh to be honest
i didn't i'm like this is definitely
fake man this is what the hell this is
not real
and then he was showing me because the
guy had no handiness on technology
but i looked at the iphone you know
sometimes you can see the location at
the time and everything so it was filmed
on his phone
there's nothing fake about this so i was
like that's mad and then the fact that
it's someone i know as well that's just
losing it and like how projecting a
different voice
um that was like insane to me but then i
look at this person
and even after they got healed they're
not looking after themselves
they're listening to music they're doing
things that are
allowing the shaytan to come into their
house they're careless and
obviously if you're going to be careless
it's going to happen to you again
obviously some people can like do it
through
magic or it can come through many ways
allah alm what
this jin specific i don't know the full
story the full detail but i just know
that this specific person
is careless still to this day you think
that after
you you know something happens to you
especially with you know the jin the
khalas you're going to look after
yourself and
you know you're going to you know make
sure you're you're praying your prayers
on time
doing your ethical stuff like that but
obviously if you're not doing it then
you're not protecting yourself these are
the things that allah subhanahu wa
and the prophet salallahu have told us
about to protect yourself from these
things and if you're not utilizing it so
i just don't feel bad for you if that's
happening
i don't know that's like the only only
things like one i saw in person the
other one i saw on someone's phone that
i didn't believe and then i
scoured through their phone i was like
you know show the location everything
i'm like that's
my money it like reinforced it it was
like when i was older this was like
three years ago he's like oh let me show
you a video and i'm like
i watched it i'm looking at him he's
like a 55 year old man i'm like
this this guy know how to photoshop
anything would he know how to fake a
video
and i was looking through his i was like
giving me the iphone it was an iphone
and then you could see that
uh it was mad and that was like another
reinforcements panel
yeah just the cross between like and dmt
and gin is is
is mad anyways but any more we just look
after ourselves we make our
car that's it that's all you can do in
it i mean what are you just
soaking all this knowledge in bro
there's no lighting rami's always
just soaking in bro rami has a lot to
say yeah but on a podcast
he's just changed watching me man talk
bro
bro first i was gonna ask uh what do you
recommend
for like daily afkar for protection bro
it's just the basics man you do your
morning afkar
you know and then before you go to sleep
also you have to have a daily daily
daily dose of your quran but here's the
thing especially with quran you're
praying five times a day
let's say minimum and you're praying
with the same sodas over and over again
how are you going to experience the
leather the beauty of prayer sometimes
you feel in some kind of way and you're
like let me read what sort of off the
head
of the death and it kind of puts you
reminds you
another time you feel in another kind of
way you read sort of
you know and it's like you enjoy it i
feel like when you have like a little
uh selection and you're just going
through
every single time even though even
though listen there's there's nothing
wrong with it there was a story where
the sahaba complained to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi i'm over sahabi always
reciting
and yeah the prophet goes because
like i love it and i want to please
allah with it and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
for that you're going to enter gender
and that's just but i'm just saying in
general
in terms of like just having the the
letter in your prayer and your salah in
your quran
when you have options when you have
variety it's always better so obviously
the quran is the major factor as well
bro that's him i just called you as well
i heard the quran playing in the back
in your house man that's yeah that's
that's it as well that that keeps
the shayating out there's a story i
heard about the specific shift one of
those jin stories but he was saying that
someone sent jin like a set to do sehar
on him and
he ended up not getting possessed his
neighbor got possessed
why because the june couldn't enter no
way and he didn't want to go back to the
set
he didn't want to go back to the
magician and be like listen it was a
failed mission so he's like what's the
next best thing the next house they're
blaring the music the chili's like right
cool let me enter here and
not get back because i don't want to
come back and tell them i couldn't even
enter the house
so then when they were like doing rokia
he was like i'm not even supposed to be
here i'm supposed to
go to this man's house next door and i
just couldn't end it because that's the
quran
consistently you know is major bro
because you're talking about the
unseen right imagine all the times allah
has protected you the quran what allah
has blessed us with has protected us and
we don't even know
and another thing with the quran never
mind yeah we're human beings bro we all
go through something
you know we all have our highs and lows
and sometimes you're on a low
and let's just say you're moving math
i'm specifically speaking about myself
here yeah
and then out of nowhere because you've
memorized a certain verse
at your youth it just comes to you bro
at that specific time
and you're just like wow i'm really here
right now i'm really doing this
whenever you're in a situation it
reminds you what are you doing
you think about it and there's no excuse
you quite literally from from the jinn
but also from yourself
from from the nephilim what's the
difference between us
and the non-believers yeah non-believers
he took his hawa his nephew as a god
he's just following his desires and it
feels good at the time for a short term
it feels good
yeah and sometimes your nephew will take
you there but then that quran will
protect you from your nephs from your
own self
if you read it with tamar if you read it
with and you contemplate with tadebo
quran do they not contemplate on the
quran some people it's on their tongues
but it's not in their hearts they're
reading it and they're just reading it
but they're not reading it
literally taking it all with every and
looking at why was this
verse revealed uh what can i learn from
this verse how can i apply it today in
this certain situation how can i apply
it into my
life now it's like there's an emphasis
of you know who has a nice voice and who
can
you know recite in a nice way in this
certain macaum or certain
oh like it sounds so good and it's
getting to the point where it's like
you know it's becoming pop culture you
know and with the
so much audience and i hope the people
they listen to these beautiful words
but they like take from and like by the
way i'm saying this from experience
i'll post like a deep on my tick tock
for example yeah
yeah and then you just see the comments
some people joking and stuff like i'm
like bro
you don't know what i'm saying right now
i'm like this verse is so deep
there should be like crying emojis in
this thing allah says
if we put this quran on a mountain
you'd see you'd see this mountain
this mountain can literally go down just
because of this quran and because the
weight of it bro
um so that's the thing it's you're
guiding
your guiding torch we're not perfect as
human beings you know we all
have our ups and downs and stuff like
that and if you have the quran by your
side
you know and you sometimes you find like
people saying oh for example
he didn't learn quran or whatever it
he goes i wish i had more time not doing
jihad and reading quran
and by the way she had his the top three
one of the top threes in islam in terms
of reward
not only that khalid when he reads the
quran he will understand it better than
me and you
because their arabic is not like arabic
sometimes us arabic speakers are not
even arabic speakers
you we think we know arabic bro but we
don't know arabic like they did his dad
was
he was a poet and that's why if
became muslim probably all of mecca
would have become muslim but heard about
him going and listening to the quran
from the prophet sallallahu alaihi so he
freaked
out his ego that's because they were
known for the sheriff they're known for
the poetry they were known
for understanding the depth of the quran
that's why when the quran came
it was like a miracle bro you know you
say that to anybody else they're like
how is that a miracle it's a book you
know but because you don't understand
the depth of it
in terms of the linguistics in terms of
how
expressive it is in terms of just so
many
scientific miracles there's so many
different variants that just make it
insane
and not only that back then they didn't
even know there were scientific miracles
right now it's unfolding before our eyes
subhanallah
they would just read and they would
believe and that's it
if you look at prophet musa he came at a
time of magic so
allah gave him the staff and that's what
caused people to uh believe in him
because you know the magicians they
themselves were like
this is not even magic when he uh
came up against them and then there was
isa ali salam
he came at the time of medicine and at
the time of medicine
you'd even raise the dead with the will
of allah
so people are like whoa okay so he's
coming at the time of medicine and he's
doing
these medical uh miracles and then the
prophet salallahu came at the time of
poetry where the arabs were so profound
in their
speech and the way uh they expressed
themselves because that was the arab
peninsula there wasn't much
there was just people writing poetry
sometimes even a line of poetry could
destroy tribes but he came and he was
illiterate as well subhanallah and
that's the miracle
well we have a lot of brothers and
sisters that are watching that are
reverts
and they never you know learn tedu
either you know how to recite
and they just they just look at like
english translations
knowing that it won't really be the full
thing there's a lot of other people that
are just reciting but they don't look at
the meaning
and one group says no reciting is better
the other group says no it's just you
know
understanding it is more important so
what do you have to say to that
i feel so bad for people who can't like
fully take it in arabic it's such a
world
of different sometimes i'm reading a
verse and i'm like yo let me check the
translation just to
you know know how to say in english and
then i'm like
bro that's that is the meaning but it
doesn't hit the same
like i said for me you do all three at
the time of
ramadan you recite after ramadan you
memorize
and you memorize so you have like i said
variety you can
uh you know it shields and enforces
certain things within you
at times where you feel you know you can
slip away
you don't have to memorize the quran but
it's better if you do the prophet
when you know that what is when it gets
difficult on the battlefield
it goes in where the people of quran the
prophet
was like described as he was a quran
that was
used to walk on the ground with his his
mannerisms
his way of expressing himself to the
people
he had the quran and how do you do that
bro
when you memorize it you contemplate on
it you know you understand it
i'm not saying memorize all of it
the best of you are the people who learn
the quran and teach it i think it's it's
important bro for everyone to you know
have a even a bit of a relationship with
the quran you know
yeah that's facts bro when you said
relationship it just reminded me of this
running joke on youtube and tech talk
about you finding wifey bro
so what's going on with that bro i know
you you said you're talking
are you are you in a place right now
where you're just you're not honestly
you're actively seeking nah people think
i'm not looking or or something like
that i don't know
um but yeah i'm on i'm on the hunt
but i feel like it's it's difficult man
i'll tell you why yeah and i don't know
about you there's a
there's so many different variants and
factors but
i don't know social media bro it's
there's maybe
guys please talk man because i've been
talking the whole time
uh you know are you married faith yeah
i'm married
maybe i'm looking in the wrong place or
i've had a few
mishaps i feel like the standards have
gotten so much lower since i hopped on
social media bro because
for me when i first got on yeah hijab
was a certain thing
he used to think whatever these girls
are wearing is not hijab
and i became complacent all i clocked
this the other day
when my mom was like listen i'm trying
to find you a wife at least help me out
what do you like
and i'm like here and she's like what's
this
i'm like funny super like like this girl
she's like yeah yeah first of all she
does her eyebrows
she puts on makeup so how she making
will go she's obviously
just very fashionably i'm like oh my god
i didn't even think about the makeup
little thing i didn't think about the
eyebrow thing it's just because i've
become so accustomed to it through
scrolling
scrolling and scrolling scrolling halas
it became everyone's like that
and it's just become the norm to me and
it's become normalized in my head and
the girl was
if you'd see her you'd be like okay yeah
she's not that bad i showed it to my mom
she's like what are you doing bro you
know what stop looking for a wife i'm
going to look forward to
i'm like also because there's so many
options options options options options
and when does it stop you just need to
just pick one and just go for it and
just that's what my brother was telling
me he was like
just pick one and that's it and then
also
let's say she takes everything then
there's like
certain ideas that have creeped in that
are not so islamic
i'm broke they're fine how does that
take everything then
no they take everything on the surface
when you get talking the more you find
out the more you just unveil that like
my values and your values are completely
different for me if you say
i'm going to that's it i'm going to look
into it
yeah and i will change my position in a
snap
in a heartbeat but if you say to them
there's
a lot of mujahideen there's a lot of
like oh no
i'm not generalizing here i'm not
generalizing you know i'm just saying
from my personal experience and it's
only two times
but it's difficult you know and and you
know what the fight against islam bro
comes within
they've spent a lot of money fighting
the dean
ideologically and one of them is the
moderate islam
and adding moderate to islam and let's
change a few things about the dean oh no
that's
barbaric we can't do that oh no how can
you do that you know and it's just like
there's more and more and the more you
kind of get into that khalas it's a
slippy slope allah says
that's the media they want to extinguish
the law of allah
with their mouths
continue his life whether they like it
or not whether the disbelievers like it
or not but they're spending so much
money on this propaganda bro
have the stuff on social media bro even
when you look at the palestine
uh situation people got their tick tock
removed the posts have been and that's
just a very
very very very very very basic white and
black
never mind the little doubts they add
into the muslims lives
on social media and the amount of times
they promote certain creators
to add these doubts into the most the
muslim or muslims mind i'm talking about
guys i'm not even talking about
and the thing is for us i don't know if
it's just the western muslims the ones
that grew up and the west
i don't know from but from experience
i'm talking to
i just realized that there's a lot of
these ideas that have crept in
like i've said they've spent a lot of
money
disbelievers they will spend their money
to come in the way
of the path of allah they will spend it
from taking
then they will regret it then they will
be
then they will lose so in the end of the
day bro it is
obviously still people there that are
good and
it's just a matter of time and it's a
matter of patience and it's a matter of
also um yeah
you know it's that's that's that like
yeah i was just gonna say that you know
the most important thing when
looking for a marriage is that you ask
allah and you praise tahara and that you
make lots of
that you you look for what allah has
decreed for you and how do you know
that this is for you well you praise
tahara and you go for it and if allah
makes it easy as the dua
says if it's good for me in my present
and future life then make it easy for me
and if allah makes it difficult for you
then okay it's not meant to be
but this is why it's so important to
have yourself established and i don't
just mean in terms of like oh financial
stability and all that but establishing
your own character in your dna religion
uh your everything character indeed as a
fossil
if you establish yourself in these
things you have your principles down
not only are you going to be able to vet
people based on what
appearance but you'll be able to to vet
them based on
ideological beliefs and so on and so
forth and it won't bother you
when they don't meet that because you
know within yourself
what you need in a spouse and you know
that allah just this is not for you and
allah is probably saving you for
something
i got a question for both of you all so
yeah what's going on about how
there is there's this you're the married
woman why are you asking questions
i got you i got you but this is gonna be
for single people so for you two
um there's this proclivity that men have
when they're single that they wanna get
married make everything halal
you know lower the gays i i understand
that we should all get married asap but
there's also people that are rushing
into marriage and they're not ready so
how do you guys find that
sweet spot in your opinion between
waiting but not waiting till you're like
30 40.
um i would say oh yeah i would say um
you have to meet the islamic criteria
and what is the islamic criteria
that you are mature mentally physically
and emotionally how do you know that
you're not mature
you're able to carry and fulfill the
rights of your wife the rest of your
family
you're able to provide what islam says
you have to provide
you have some kind of income you're not
a lazy bum sitting eating
lace chips all day uh watching yaki's
vlogs
you know you're right
you're working and then you watch his
vlogs on your free time masha allah
yes of course we're productive out here
maybe lose track of time bro sometimes
man mashallah man
sick editing that you do bro mashallah
nice to my nice one that's a nice one i
need to step it up even later
so i i i make is lose more of your time
but now you learn you pick up a few
things here and there but yeah rami
answered that perfect man i don't even
have to
add one thing to that one that's perfect
literally exactly what you said on me
i'm with you 100
i want to add one more thing um because
the birth of one extreme birth's the
opposite extreme right so we have two
extremes nowadays
we have the extreme of you know a 30
year old whose mom is saying no you're
too young to get married
and you have the extreme of the 13 year
olds who's still in middle schools that
want to get married
right and maybe the 30 year old isn't
ready and maybe the 13 year old is
but this is why they're extremes because
they're very rare occurrences but what
you want to make sure is that you're not
falling
into any either of these extremes so
start with that
am i falling into an extreme and use the
guidelines of of
islam as as we mentioned to actually see
if you're there yet
and then apply those same standards
islamically to the one you're you're
looking to
marry in sha allah bro we have this
running joke whenever we go on live
people don't believe in bengali
just take that no i didn't think bro i
didn't think you're a bengali man
what would you say i think you're a
half african brother yeah i get a bra i
get that
half arab you know what yeah what's
what's your favorite yeah what's your
man
you could say like my grandmother is
from crete from greek
but she her family escaped when the omen
empire fell so they went to libya
some went to syria somewhat that was
pretty much like the most
diverse see libya
grew up in ireland libyan group in
ireland
yeah so bro a lot of people have have
this pressure from their parents that
you gotta marry within our race
you gotta marry within our ethnicity and
islam
just doesn't stop there right you can
marry any other you know ethnicity
what do you say um
no i can't say it's an asian thing to be
honest because i was talking to one of
my mates who's libyan
who also their mum's like admin that he
gets married
um what do i say right yeah like are you
are you are you praying
hate that are you promising i hate that
bro i hate nationalism on a different
level
yeah such a genie thing you know and
that's just nationalistic no it's not
even
we're trying to don't it's dumb bro
it's just i think he said something to
be led you know his skin color we really
went to the prophet
he complained to me and he goes
you are a person who has still inside
them and then i think dharr
literally went down to him and like
please take care of the sauce for me you
know i'm so sorry and that's just that
bro that's just
just ignorance on a different level you
think i'm better than you because
you were born in a specific spot or
because you know your dad's not
so-and-so
you know the best of you the ones who
are most righteous that's the standard
you're gonna pick a brother or a sister
based on their righteousness
and that's that if you're looking at
obviously the sister she needs to
have a few extra criterias you know can
he provide for me xyz but for god
hey is she righteous don't tell me where
she's from where dad is who
this i don't care i think you know i
literally that's the last thing and
that's
i hate nationalism with a passion
because that's the thing that's dividing
us
nationalism bro you know and within
pakistan within libya within specific
areas
they'll say like in libya we have
he's from the west he's from the east
and then within you go into benghazi
ah he's from an area of so-and-so ah
he's from this specific tribe
when does an end grow when does the
division end when does the segregation
end
when islam comes into play in people's
lives and they realize
there's no difference between an arab
and a non-arab will it be about
what not white no black only with
righteousness
that's it because the division will
never end
it's kind of long though honestly with
me i was this is something that i i hate
like i think on a whole other level
because i was actually the first time i
tried to get married i was in the
talking stage and all that
i was actually rejected because of my
background because i'm
not because i'm palestinian but because
i wasn't from the place that they're
from
my friend actually got rejected um
actually maybe i shouldn't include this
but
it was the opposite he wasn't
palestinian really
i mean i i do know some palestinians are
like that there was actually an elderly
man male 1
uh from the the masjid i used to go to
before i moved
i told him about this like talking thing
and trying to get married
and i was trying to become an
electrician at the time right so i need
to do an apprenticeship and it was hard
to find one he's like listen i know
apprentices
or i know i know people electricians to
get you an apprenticeship
leave this marriage thing with this
non-palestinian girl
and try and find a palestinian girl i'll
get you an apprenticeship and i'm like
bro
it's like that man that's a different
level
bro i i well i i couldn't look in the
same academy
and i mean honestly there is some level
of truth because if we're being honest
if the
if the man or the woman is from a place
where
their culture is so isolating just
towards them alone
then it may actually cause problems in
the marriage which means you
maybe shouldn't marry them like if you
come from a culture
that only allows you to marry within
that culture it might not be the worst
thing to stick to that because there's a
chance that if you go against it
your marriage life is going to suck
because you don't marry the person you
marry the family you marry the cultural
family you're married
your culture as well um but it's sad
because it starts with culture ruining
everything and invading islam
so it goes back to what he said yeah
that we need to implement islam properly
and it starts with you know things like
this we need to teach people
what islam actually says and allah says
in the quran that he
create actually i don't want to miss
quote i want you to quote it but
basically the
i in the quran allah says that he
created us in different
ways so that we can learn about each
other
yeah different tribes and different
nations but in the end of the day
the best of you i think i've mentioned
that quote uh just earlier
who are the most righteous that's the
thing bro like
like you just it's just a place of
identification
it's just i'm from this place i'm from
that place okay
and that's that and you get on with it
you don't judge people based on where
they're from or how they look or
that's basics man but it's still uh
within people's
you know hearts and it's just a bit of
ignorance you know
and may allah keep us away from that man
because
you know you never want that creeping in
yeah i mean you're up i mean
100 um but i do feel like our generation
is a lot less cultural
than our family generation because a lot
of them i think maybe the internet broke
the barriers
a lot yeah yeah
yeah i would i would agree i would agree
honestly um like
before fed i wouldn't talk to him he's a
bengali like
me but now since
he's just like yeah bro
he's speaking me knowing romney for like
two three years now we used to talk
about how
he was you know he was into tick tock
but i'm not saying he's not into tick
tock anymore but
there's reasons bro there's reasons that
tick-tock isn't the best app
definitely i want to know about your
relationship with tick-tock bro i'm
probably the exact same and honestly
yeah when i first got cracking on it
i don't think there was any quran on the
app so i was like oh be nice if i can
and my mom hates social media you know
so the only way
she's she's going to let me do social
media is if i you know put the quran
says
i'm going to put quran make her happy
because she's a quran teacher you know
may allah bless it
so i start pointing quran and i was like
this is a good sadhaka
because you never know if you when you
pass away you pass away you die
and it's going to happen to everyone
couldn't necessarily every soldier
for you then to have something as i said
is
it's beautiful man you know for me it i
i'm finding you know because sometimes
you have to keep up with the trends
and then also i don't listen to music
and i'm not saying like i don't listen
to music because
oh i'm so religious whatever i just
literally find it boring i can't
i listen to podcasts and that's that
music
when i used to listen to it i'd kind of
like get bored switch songs get bored
switch song
and there's nothing there's no meaning
to it these days you know but even if
you put on a nasheed there's proper
poetry
you know it strengthens your arabic so i
just felt it counter-productive like i
didn't but then when i started using
tik-tok
you have to be up to trends or you don't
have to be both like if you want to like
boost your video and get on the
algorithm you need to use the music
that's popping you know so that's the
thing that
kind of got me back into that which i'm
trying to do less of anna even on my on
my youtube videos
i'm trying to like just stick to sound
designing the videos because bro
it's for some people it's not as
entertaining if there's not like a bit
of music in the back or a bit of
you know um you know the tune they like
so
i think it's a silence a weapon of
two edges now what do you want to do
with it you want to do that
like rami used to always do and i think
still does he refutes people on it but a
lot of people i'd say i found the slam
through tiktok
and it comes right to their for you page
and
a lot of people who are muslims who
never identified with islam they were
just muslim by name
are now learning things because it's
just coming into their for you page
whether they liked it or not and you
know they have a bit of goodness in
their heart and they're sticking
to the video and they're watching it and
they're learning some things that are
new as long as you're producing it and
not
consuming too much then obviously it can
kind of lead to other things but but
allow adam if
if muhammad if it's the
sin is greater than the reward it's like
for me anyways i'm going to
try my best to kind of post my
videography on it my art
which gets a crazy amount of reach on
tick-tock comparing to any other
social media so it's good and bad bro
you know as long as you keep the screen
time low on it
and you just stick to producing and not
consuming too much
yeah it should be all right hello adam
what do you think
i haven't heard that 100 bro i agree 100
man like i haven't posted a lot recently
because the last video i tried to post
didn't go up because it was a bit i
don't know it violated community
guidelines whatever yeah i was
refuting someone and the whole thing
about entertainment bro it's 100 true
you need to have something that is
catchy enough to keep
the viewer and it's sad because it's
only for a minute but that's the essence
of the app right
um the reason my account started to blow
up is because
of the refutations because when you have
someone's face someone on the line
and like they get cut off and then
someone else comes on and starts
refuting them it's like a drama show
and people love that but if you could
use that to teach people something like
aisha's age
or um the prophet and like
and all of that stuff and teaching about
the history the context the quran so on
and so forth
if they can learn about it then okay
but i would relate it to i would say
it's it's similar to just being
out and anonymous what were they saying
about benue though sorry
well you know like oh the prophets allah
said just about how
like you know yeah like how we kill the
jewish tribe and all this stuff
yeah but people don't know that this was
according to the jewish law this is
according
and read the verse bro they knew it
themselves they knew what was going to
happen to them anyways
exactly no exactly like exactly like you
said they broke a treaty
and what happened treason is like the
worst man the most punishable
act is treason and they knew it
themselves and that's why they didn't
even want to
let the so they were like let us pick
from our friends from our people who are
now muslim and they chose
who were their allies before islam and
they used to trade with them and stuff
like that
but you know what i love about that when
they chose who did they choose they
choose uh sadly
all the people have always to go up to
them and they say sad please
look after our allies and then he just
says this very famous quote
goes
to not fear the blame of the blamers and
let's say they knew at that time
they knew because then he came and he
judged on the prophet salallahu
says
what is above seven heavens so allah's
judgment you have given it
exactly the way it is you know but
that's such a powerful statement
not to fear the blame of the blamers
yeah the thing is especially nowadays
you fear the blame of the blamers you
fear what they're going to say about you
people's idea of you and your image
means allah
and it's fundamental for a muslim
to first of all not fear the blame of
the blamers and allah even describes
a certain fear of people who
do not fear the blame of the believers
and allah says he loves them and they
love him
or those who believe if you
yet if you leave this deen and by
leaving this deen and it's not not
believing or not acknowledging
it's you going into a market and like
you know choosing islam
and you're choosing this and you're not
choosing that that's
you're not taking everything you're not
picking up the banner exactly the way
allah prescribed it to you
for suffering then allah will replace
you allah will bring
people allah loves him and he loves them
what are their qualities
you know they fear they care about the
believers you know wherever they are in
the in the land they speak about them
they support them they go to them
they have you know on the disbelievers
and their religion you know they're
they stand up for what is right
they find in the way of allah and they
do not fear the blame of the blamers
yeah
and that's gonna listen if you don't if
you want to go and you want to pick
this and that and whatever because it
doesn't suit your feminist agenda
yeah allah will replace you that's it
it's easy as that because
in the end of the day in the end of the
day allah is gonna give victory
with me or without me with you or
without you
he does not need you you need
to be part of this yeah you know that
kind of way yeah
so bro that that's uh that quote
he said in a letter
i mean that's something that we lost we
you know as an uma we lost our eyes that
we lost our honor
right like man bro i hate well i hate to
admit this but i'm gonna say it because
man it's true it's real
and it used to be me and like grade
nine grade ten bro i was so stupid
i told someone i was half muslim as if i
was like like in ethnicity
i swear to god bro i'm like yeah i'm
half muslim like and they're like what
the hell
bro but it's it's sad because some
people technically are half muslims you
know what i mean like
like he was saying it's like going to
the market picking this and picking that
and saying i don't really want that you
know it doesn't fit my style essentially
and voila bro it's sad it's sad but
that's that's bro and you're saying that
out loud there's a lot of people that
won't say out loud but that's what they
feel inside yeah you know
and bro you're young as well like you're
you're a kid and
you know any everywhere you look
especially now there's not social media
to like reinforce
um what's right because now you know a
lot of right
and truth is coming out you know through
people on social media even though it's
kind of low-key being suppressed
but before bro there was nothing there
was just mainstream media
it's why you were fed on tv you know and
the thing is
the muslims believe it bro the muslims
believe every single
ounce of it like they just handed in
just take everything in
allah
make sure it's true that's the first
thing to say not muslim he didn't say
someone that's
actively fighting you he didn't say
someone that's actively trying to change
your religion he said that
so someone who was very light on the
religion you know you know he goes out
and drinks and asks
what he does but you know that from you
know what is apparent from him
then double check we're not even double
checking what the disbelievers are the
people that are trying to fight the dean
of allah saying
you just take it as face value and
that's that you know and that's what's
happening and that's what used to happen
now i think
uh less so because people have less
trust in the mainstream but bro it was
difficult you know
let's say 15 years back or you know 10
years back especially when you were like
eight or whatever
uh 9 10 that's all you saw
and it's like what the hell man what do
i believe what narrative is this and
you're just getting the same
narrative yeah and it's been fed day
after day after day after day
alas it's gonna become the truth you
know after a while the lies
they become the truth unfortunately if
you do not tabay and if you do not like
you know
search for the truth but that's the
thing as a muslim bro
we should always be searching for the
truth we do not follow this
religion blindly
with vision and like because i know you
know the truth and the hack
are the people that know that the truth
has come to you from allah i like the
ones who are blind
that's the muslim man he's
does not get bitten from the same hole
twice you have to be on the ball with
these things
especially nowadays but but where does
that start feeling your honor and your
deen and implementing your deen it all
starts with learning islam
can't practice your religion we feel
honorable that you practice islam if you
don't know islam
it's like saying you love allah but you
don't know any of his names you don't
know his attributes you don't know
anything about allah
it's like saying you have a best friend
that you know nothing about it doesn't
make sense
so how is this your way of life if you
don't even know about it subhanallah
so muslims need to start taking
an effort the same way they go to school
they make the effort to wake up and go
to school and all that stuff
they need to wake up make the effort to
go learn about islam get a teacher
take a course something man i three
institute dot dot c is really good
inshallah
um bro the thing is even the role models
man
who are the role models you say tell
them name
and sahabah name ten of the companions
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
they won't you tell them barcelona
they'll give you the 11th start and
you know the the the 24 squad full no
problem
they'll tell you who the coaches they'll
tell you the scores that the the goals
that were scored in 2018
2016 allah added me it's mad if your
role models
are the sahaba bro then you're going to
know their life
you're going to know obviously if you're
going to know this haba's life you're
going to have to know the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's life
you know because that's how you discover
you're like oh that's actually such a
brave uh courageous thing that he did
let me look into
you know this specific sahabi let me
look into that specific sahab
you know so you fight you follow the
seed of the prophet
and then you take these people as your
role models you know
and then you implement what they done in
their life you implement in years or you
try
your best because that's what role
models are for like you
people that you look up to you you know
you do your best to um
you know
i don't know i just seen you know what
happened yeah i seen the boxing bag
and it made sense why it fit it was his
name fit
yeah sorry that was complete
is that a boxing bag yeah yeah yeah
because i was like speaking and i was
looking at like because i have boxes my
man
my man notice that one hour yeah
i didn't know what it is though because
i have a heavy bag as well but i don't
have it indoors i think that that's what
threw me off mm-hmm
but yeah bro this one day when i was
watching one of your vlogs
you you said something uh like solo
traveling is underrated
i thought i was the only one thinking
that bro because it truly is underrated
just being on your own terms yeah you're
like you're like a nomad just
like i need to start traveling again
coveting brokovic just got in the way
bro
ruined it yeah yeah traveling's classman
you know it's uh
such a thing that most people just don't
expect because there's a lot of fear
related to it you know
what are you doing what are you doing in
september bro september
what are you doing in september we're
going to puerto rico bro oh
that's actually a good one september why
not
bro there was some boys actually they
were going to do amber as well in
june but i don't think they went through
because of this whole cobra thing so i
said i'll join as well
so hold on yeah why not my puerto rico
it is
it's a close close thing from canada i
have to cross the ocean for you guys
why not why not bro why not
but that's not going to be a solo thing
man that's going to be a jamaat thing
yeah there you go
there's not much i could uh you know say
i always get that generic question about
what's your favorite country i don't
know man
it's the same
same every time it's you can't really
choose because the thing is
if i go to turkey for example one time
and
you know i'm on a specific budget um you
know i come winter season it's not going
to be the same as
if i have like a better budget
summertime you know if i stay in this
specific place or that specific you're
always going to change your perspective
depending on your situation you get me
so i can't really say but i think one of
the
most underrated spots for me anyways was
turkey and indonesia
indonesia was different level as well um
so yeah definitely uh turkey in
indonesia
turkey you just see everything there's
so many different variants bro
there's the sea there's the city there's
that kappa doki
is a madness bro you know sometimes you
go to a spot and you're like
what is this this is actually instagram
live
like right there it's mad because you a
lot bro the amount of times you get
catfish when you're traveling you see a
spot on
on instagram you're like right i'm gonna
go there and then you show up and you're
like what the hell is this
catfished on a different level but thank
you man turkey's sick
so i like this is the real deal bro yeah
i'd say i like turkey and indonesia and
indonesia's class as well i want to go
back and explore indonesia proper
because i got injured when i was in
indonesia i had a little biking accident
but
inshallah go back indonesia i think
indonesia is definitely on the books
you don't got like stuff that's
prohibiting you from traveling like
school
or work or anything like that i'm
finished school
okay finish school in terms of work i'm
self-employed
so i work for myself i can literally
just take litchi
today it took off tomorrow i can take
off the next week
it comes to a certain point where you
have to work but um that's the beauty of
being a freelancer
i'm a freelance videographer so it's
handy bro and you just
you dedicate your own hours to pick
you know what you want to do but when i
was traveling um
i also done a bit of social media
marketing on the side because obviously
you know when you make videos for
clients um
there was one client i was like bro
you're spending all this money with me
man what are you doing
what are you doing with these videos and
he was saying i'm actually just posting
them on social media and i'm like right
let me run facebook and instagram ads
for you let's see what we can do from
there
i don't know for a bit i was very
successful at it
but i didn't like it because i was just
spending people's money and i was just
like
it's constantly on the back of my mind
bro i'll be like sleeping
middle of the night wake up go down
check my laptop sometimes like i'd
unplug my laptop hide this so i don't do
it
but i'd like literally wake up in the
middle of the mic go downstairs
look for my laptop plug it in open it
wait for it to boot
and then you know as manager would pop
up i'm like okay yeah that's performing
and i don't know why i thought and it's
i didn't like it you know it just
different people different you know this
suits them but it was nice because i
could travel and do it as well
you know and so
yeah that's bro that's why working
online's elite
i'd recommend every muslim even in
general to just try to work for
themselves
or establish a little side hustle you
know at the beginning like obviously you
can't
start off like that straight away but if
you can you know take a skill hone it
and then try to go your own way
so you know you dedicate your own hours
and you don't have a boss telling you oh
sorry bro you can't pray man
it's our time yeah no sorry and it's
just like what can you do
and what'd you study bro what'd you
study in school i did biomedical science
two years done like an internship in st
james hospital
and it was like probably top of the
range
in terms of facilities the people um
the research we were doing was ovarian
cancer
and i just didn't like it i was doing
like three months of it
it was a lab we couldn't see daylight
during the day obviously go out and
we're lucky because during the summer
you know it would get back at ten
so i'd leave it at six and i'd still
have four hours but bro i could not
imagine doing that in the winter
you come in when it's dark and you leave
when it's dark
i saw people that were passionate about
it and you know when a certain result
would pop up they'd be celebrating and
they're happy and
for me it just didn't do that for me you
know so
i was like well i'm gonna take a year
off i'm gonna try to figure out what i
want to do
and then i started making videos and
then i was like you know maybe i could
you know take this into a profession
maybe i can you know
um i like this i can express myself with
it videos are powerful
especially if it's done correct you're
influencing emotion if you influence
emotion
you literally have the grasp
of what people think and perceive
you know that's why it's very dangerous
when i was first started making videos
it made me feel a kind of way it made
people feel a con away
and i was like i need to make more of
this and i like this and you know
it kind of like kindled my passion for
it
and i started it and you know and we're
here alhamdulillah
i didn't go back so a 10 minute video on
average that
you post on youtube how long would that
take time always depends depends depends
depends
you never know like uh like my videos
now bro i literally filmed them on the
iphone
you know like the the youtube ones and
because i realized especially
because they're not traveling the travel
ones obviously i film on my camera but
first of all when i was making the
travel videos they never they always
get nowhere near as much views because
people don't care about it like you know
as much as you think people just want to
see me just chat
so i'm like right i'll just give the
people what they want and then be with
me later
you know so right now i'm just you know
filming off my phone just to make it
easy bro
i bang out vlogs like i can do in a day
like filming
in a day because it's my phone like no
problem um and
you know inshallah when i get to
traveling again inshallah the next
destination i want to find like a cause
or or something because the last one i
don't
when i was in vietnam is the the muslims
in vietnam we've raised their hands
nearly i don't know how many dollars
like 43k
uh dollars so i'm trying to send that
over between
and we get crack i'm gonna visit them
obviously
to just update everyone on the situation
what's happening and what we've built
and
you know all of that um and
i just want to like travel find
different projects people that need to
help muslims around the world
and wherever they are film it and then
do some hair with it together so that's
that's the plan being late
i don't know if you've answered your
question i'm probably going down like
three different tangents
it's always sufficient bro ramen what's
on your mind
well honestly may allah bless you and
that and make it easy for you and
allow it to to produce hair for everyone
the one question i had how do you find
good deals for flights or is that
for flights bro i'm not going to light
him on
um i'm so bad man
and only the thing is you have sky
scanner but then also
when you're flexible it's a lot easier
you get me when you're flexible with the
dates
it's a lot easier like if you don't like
i said if you're freelance doing your
own thing like
oh 28th is you know nine euro flight
could bro
within europe it's cheap man i was
looking to fly
bro i was looking at a flight to turkey
just the other day it was like nine quid
i'm like what the hell what am i doing
here me but um
i have i have someone finished business
but i'm literally going to go do a
mission to
to i was like to my brother's mind my
younger brother
i was like you wanna do turkey
well we'll look into us maybe in two
weeks inshaallah
that'll be the next destination turkey
but it's cheap bro when you live in
europe
it's lovely and it's not like canada and
america where it's oh i don't have to
think about the
the prices bro okay nine euro is a bit
of an exaggeration it is non-euro but
it's not always like that
but like bro max it's like a hundred
quid
you know 80 70's
average so it's like obviously if you
want to go further
i don't really usually anywhere that's
further it's
cheap to live and
you know spend money there but it's
expensive to get there
europe is the opposite it's cheap to get
there but it's expensive
so you end up spending the same anyways
you know
yeah um and in terms of like hotels and
stuff like that i just on the spot bro
sometimes i just land into the airport
and then like
i'll be looking through what hotels
available and then
book on the spot and go to the taxi like
take me here as long as it's like 100
meters or whatever from the city center
and then we figure out you know bro i
always wanted to travel and and just do
um
bro and i saw your vlog i got something
to do with that one
i got so lucky with that bro tell me
more about that bro cause when kovit hit
i'm just like bro i gotta put my plans
on pause how was that
the fact that so many things aligned on
that trip it was mad
that's what happens bro when you have a
bit of tawak and a lot of penalties and
just going with it and just being like
i'm gonna just do it that's it like i
missed my flight with my mate he went
back and i'm like you know i missed it
for a reason
i'm gonna go and and i explored the
region and then the fact that i found
the vietnamese people
the muslims and um two years it broke
what's mad i remember at the time when i
when i met the sheikh
of the school he was like we need 25
grand for the water project
i'm thinking in my head who does he
think i am does he think i'm some rich
boy like
i don't i don't have a spare 25k to give
you like in my head i'm like yeah
inshallah
and he said this two years ago and
then when i posted that video it went
viral
and i was like bro i have to do
something and then my dad was like
pressing me to do it like a gofundme and
then
we raised that in like less than a week
and i'm like super
allah the fact that he mentioned to me
and i even at the time
i was just thinking i wish bro you know
but allah just makes things happen and
then
after that indonesia after that you know
when i was in indonesia my family were
missing me and they're like listen come
back
it's been i don't know i think it was
like four months five months
and i was like you know what how about
we link up for amra because they opened
up the
visas you know travel um
i don't know what it is for canada but
for us
um in europe specifically it was like
you can just
have like 90 days and you know you just
apply for online
i literally applied for it got it the
next day literally the second i got out
i booked
and then i was there my family booked it
and we were there and it was an insane
experience
and the thing is you know what else uh
speaking of saving
when people in the community found out
that
you know like my mom's friends they were
like how are you going with no travel
agent
like what are you doing especially omar
has you know obviously i think you have
to
but i was like how are you not going
with a travel agent like
it's impossible you know and i was like
listen let's just do it the way like for
me let's just
trust me and i think we calculated the
bro and we done
three weeks that three weeks equated to
one week if we done it with a travel
agent
exact everything you know so it's not
the cuts they make
um i know that's the business they're in
but it's it's insane bro if you just
kind of just do it yourself
slickman you just meet loads of people
all different uh walks of life
different experiences and bro i'm young
as well i'm not married
i don't have a lot of responsibilities
that's what even my mom was telling me
she was like when can you ever do this
again and i was lucky because covert hit
and then
it's not really as you can't travel as
fluid as that
allah adam if we ever can you know every
different place has like quarantined
standards and different requirements and
you have to keep checking if they're on
the red list or the blue list or allah
and what so
it's heavy so i got i always think about
that i'm like i got so lucky especially
that i'm on a trip man it's like
i've done it with my family and it was
oh man ahmed i was just
next level bro we were just in the hell
i'm like 24 7. you know
it's like you can't even describe him
and the feeling you get when did you go
the tranquility you feel and i went such
a good time as well it was um
it was the new years so january it was
like this
was perfect like six months
[Music]
the thing is also i
didn't plan to post any of this on
youtube i just filmed it for my own
memories and then when i got doing
tick-tock people were recognized for
youtube and i'm like
let me see what i have and i had like
hard drives like stacked
with forge so i'm like right let me see
what i can edit
and then i literally had enough to make
it 15-20 minute youtube videos
i was like okay let's just you know post
them
um so i posted it like a year late
that's why
people think like it was recent reason
but it was like literally now two years
subhanallah
the whole video was mad like it
literally flew boy and now
we're six months into 2021 oh my days
it's
insane you have to remind me it's insane
yeah
oh man it's it's insane bro it's like
how
maybe that's a sign of the the last days
times like just flying allah adam
that's crazy the concept of time so
interesting though you know that i was
listening to
um speaker the other day and he was
saying that in general times
infinite and you'll ever think about it
to be honest yeah you're like yeah
i can spend he goes times infinite
you're gonna have a month
where you can spend a summer with
for example i'm thinking yeah in my head
i remember answering them like
bro everyone's going to go to the
prophet
obviously like s going to be no time and
then he just answered it the second i
said that in my head he goes
maybe after a few billion years you know
when everyone's
met him he's going to have some time for
you and i'm like what the hell
that's my because it's eternal it's
forever and ever and
ever yeah i'm like that's so crazy
how insane is that allah um
and then even when you come back on the
day of judgment it's like
the scene how many days have you spent
on this earth you forget bro
we we we lived a day or two first and
asked the people who were counting
you know it's that's it it's mad it's
mad it's mad
time is just an insane thing especially
you know when you equate it to
you know ah sometimes you hear about
like oh you're going to be waiting for
this amount of time
for your judgment and then this amount
of time will pass for the i'm like bro
that's crazy man honestly and if you
think about it it's something that we
can
almost understand in this life because
everyone feels like life is eternal
yeah yeah yeah you remember often the
destroyer of all desires
which is death right that's why allah
reminds us
that every soul shall taste death yeah
100
the first episode we had of this podcast
we're approving god's existence
and one of the points is infinite
regression right which is basically
um you know what infinite regression is
yeah yeah yeah yeah so basically
yeah time can't be infinite because um
there's no beginning which means we
would never get to this point because
there would have to be an infinite
amount of minutes seconds
whatever time would have to pass before
we get to this point
it's kind of like um your mom has to
give birth to an infinite amount of
children before you're born would you
ever be born you wouldn't right
so janna is not like totally infinite
because it was created at a point but
it's like positively infinite
so it starts at zero and it goes one two
three four five and that is quantifiable
it just goes on for infinity and that's
kind of infinite bro subhanallah just
just thinking about that man well it's
mind-boggling and on top of that if this
life was infinite
everyone would eventually just kill
themselves if not 100 likes
you hear about people that are you know
researching into like
you know living forever and stuff like
i'm like bro like that's miserable man
there is a he was known before islam
he lived so many years
he goes he's so sick of this life that
80 years and he's seen
all his friends die and he's just sick
of it and he wants to
die as well and when he's dying he
doesn't know where he's going that's
another
crazy concept it's like at least when
you die you know there's
heaven and hell some people are they
think that's it it's over
die and it's finished you know lights
out you're going to wish that
on the day of judgment
when the animals before allah they come
because allah is all just he will take
the right of one
animal from the other and when that's
done they will turn to dust
and this believer look at them be like i
wish if only
you know ah
girl listen what has you consistent with
this month because i see a lot of people
step podcasts and then they stop after
like maybe 20
25 you're asking what house is
consistent yeah yeah
bro straight up as a man like the worst
thing you can do is set out to do
something and not follow through
yeah so i just i'm like that rami's like
the angels like that we don't have it in
us to
make a promise set up for something give
someone our word and then not really
hold it through
right we got to follow through so
december when we started this podcast
because we're only six months we
realized okay we're gonna do weekly
weekly was too easy we're like we're
gonna do two in a week and we just stuck
with it bro ever since
yeah and i think it's easier when you
have a jamaat as well when you have like
three people there everyone keeps each
other accountable you know yes
it's uh yeah man that's slickman
[Music]
tell me one thing you learned from your
mom
one of the biggest takeaways you learned
second one what's the second one
okay the first one my mother man
patience
she has a lot of patience man and um
yeah that's that's pretty much it
because my dad it relates also to my dad
my dad always speaks the truth
you know a very outspoken man and
um not only that when you're
speaking the truth politically it lands
you in you know specific areas
yeah uh so not to like go too deep into
it
but my mom stood by him 100 you know
until he was proven innocent
um from charges and stuff like that and
you know where she came from
and where she landed with my dad
she literally went from being a queen
then because
my dad spoke in a specific way and stuff
like that
money frozen everything you know
overnight bro overnight
trials tribulations and my mom stuck
through it like kids because it's the
hack
so you see that that's one of the one of
the main ones anyways
uh just having patience having somebody
having to watch
um our husband whoever
you know puts to work and allah is going
to suffice him so bro i've seen that
and that's probably yeah my my main
thing
i look up to my mom so much man i love
her so much i may allah preserve our
parents um and then my dad you know my
dad's there
he speaks the truth no matter what he
has a big character big personality
um so i picked tried to pick up a few
things
uh from him and obviously my mom also
the quran bro
like sometimes leading with her
you know after the prayer she'll be like
can you recite that i haven't made a
mistake but
can you recite that verse again i'll
recite it and be like why was that i
feel like
you you put too much you know tafreem in
the vlog or
you know you've done i'm like these are
such minor details you know
but she loves the quran so much she's a
quran teacher um and obviously i got i
you know her uh concern and her um
uh you know a love for quran
um alhamdulillah we kind of you know
my brother alhamdulillah also is uh he's
even better than me masha allah is half
of half of
you know me i'm having on paper you know
you can i can't i
like i can you know take out specific
grace i can finish it for you but
sometimes
you know inshallah may allah grant us
the ability to come back and memorize it
fully
beat me my brother's man he's 15 now i
think he finished
when he was 12 or yeah 12 13. and he
knows it knows it you know
um but that's you know because my mom
was pressing him more
than she was pressing me um but yeah man
uh that's
yeah probably the love quran and
patience what about you guys you have to
answer man
you're probably always asking that
question you've never answered it really
bro this is the first time i i
asked that oh okay one thing i learned
from my parents one one from my mom one
for my dad uh
while i gather my thoughts rami go for
it man don't do that to me i go together
bro you put me on the spot man come on
from my dad uh
just being always trying to provide
value
to whoever you come across never never
trying to be the one that always wants
to seek value
and got get caught up in that but want
to provide value
you know for my mom perseverance man
perseverance just perseverance to always
do the right thing
i love that money yeah perseverance such
a that's a rare
quality man patience perseverance um
because this life mind has a lot of
hardships do you get me
and then when you see your mother it's
inspiring like
um what about you rami honestly i'm the
host now i'm the host now
[Laughter]
we departed 2 3m now
honestly for my dad right honestly i
didn't i wasn't super super close to my
dad but because
he would work like all day every day bro
like he dropped me drop me off to school
go to work come back sometimes like when
i'm sleeping
every single day take a day off once a
while so from him man i i learned
to work hard working just to keep going
he worked like a lot man a lot and
i mean a part of me was a bit upset that
i didn't get much of him i didn't really
have you know
that side of a father but something done
man
he put in a lot of works kind of a lot
and your mother my mom
bro i learned so much from my mom made
love lester bro it's like
i don't even know where to start but to
summarize it bro empathy i learned bro
my mom is the most
empathetic person in the world and i
learned my kindness my empathy
everything from her so my love bless my
parents and then all of our parents
um yes when you hear about
us speaking about our mother's man it's
a it's different
mothers are so central bro the
upbringing of a man
i don't know maybe it's a guy's thing
maybe guys are
more inclined to their mothers and the
the girls are more inclined to their
fathers i don't know
i could be bro i i i wouldn't disagree
with 100
yeah i i feel like that to be honest it
doesn't feel like that it does seem that
way
um you know you always hear like mama's
boy and like daddy's little girl and all
that stuff i feel like there are some
truth to that
it depends but bro while we're on the
topic of mothers i want to share
something that i heard a while ago but
allah it's so i don't even know the word
bro it's so like inspiring almost
allah like you just hear it you're like
wow so i want to share that insha allah
so
the the two names of allah right
their names we recite probably the most
because you know
even saying
come from the the root word
which means the womb of a mother
and if you think about that bro that's
amazing that allah is using
the term the most merciful the
especially merciful
um using the root word of the mother's
womb
because if you look at the mother's womb
one there's nothing
really like it in you know the creation
so allah is the highest example but in
terms of a mother's womb
only only moms have that and they only
do one thing
and they protect the baby they nourish
the baby they allow the baby to grow so
much bro
and it's not and it's to the extent that
a sahabi when he carried his mother
around doing tawafra on the kaaba for
hajj or umrah
i believe it's for hajj he went to the
process him he asked did i repay her for
her carrying me
and he's like you didn't even you didn't
even pay for one kick you didn't even
pay for one kick subhanallah nothing
compares to that
and allah uses that for
and i just think that's so beautiful
subhanallah bro the amount of times my
mom used that story
[Laughter]
what are you doing you know
not even one kick or kick like what are
you doing you think uh you've done the
dishes here
you like you're left off nah come on
oh my mom used that story way too many
times or um
or even the um uh when the prophet saw i
saw him said
your mother from the moment your mother
and your mother then your father you
know so
yeah man uh but you know on tick tock
you always see like red flag if he's a
mama's boy and i'm like what
yeah oh bro how's that red flag
tell me please tell us in the comment
section if you're a sister and you think
that's a red flag please explain your
your explanation because for me that
that baffles me man
you know how's that red flag someone who
respects their mother loves their mother
um why not yeah it's not a lot
i mean i guess on this topic there is
there is an extreme
um it might not be so much about the sun
but more of the mother
um because i was actually i was sent a
tick tock recently that's like
um the mom sometimes who when she
doesn't get the emotional connection
from her husband
she gets the emotional connection from
her son and then when a woman marries
her son she feels like that emotional
connection is being stolen
so if he's a mama's boy then that might
cause problems maybe not from him but
from the mom from the mother-in-law
that's that could be a big issue
but um being a mama's boy i mean in the
in the basic term of loving your mom
and having her love you having a good
relationship being good to her um
i would say that's a plus because he's
good to his mother there's
more of a chance would be good to you
insha'allah um
but that's that's just my stance on that
let's follow the bro yeah
yeah subscribe
unless listen they're trying to get you
to you know disbelieve allah and that's
different
you know yes that's the only that's
where you draw the line basically
thanks uh with that being said
any final statements from yu yahya from
be fired
wallahi my final statement is
uh think i've used that a few times but
it's such a powerful statement use this
and not
replace us you know um may allah elevate
you guys and use our platform uh to
spread
um the truth and you know of allah
i love what you guys are doing and mad
respect
keep it up um and yeah that's
that's all i have to say man i mean
europe jazakallah we're gonna
that's all i got bro thank you so much
bro for your time
was wonderful let me end this guys
please like the video
right now what are you doing like the
video
right now if you've reached this far
like the video
and tell us that you've liked it and
share it with one of your mates
okay we need your life i'll say this
foreign
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively more than you're influencing
them positively
i think you need new friends
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
me